a greater you financially for the group
and a very good yo operationally we
produced exactly in line with the
production guidance we gave in the
market just over 27 million carats so it
was a much better year for us 2016 and
2015
so we saw at the end of 2014 and going
into 2015 that there was a little bit of
what we call indigestion in the pipeline
and that is in the rough pipeline now
it's important to remember that all ref
diamonds we largely Seraph diamonds turn
into polished diamonds which are sit and
bought by diamond jewelry consumers
around the world and we saw an
interesting phenomenon we saw that
diamond jewelry consumption in the
jewelry market was pretty good and so we
weren't really worried about global
demand but there was a bit of a stack up
of stock in the midstream the rough part
of the world so we gently reduced
production and we now find ourselves in
a position where inventory levels are
much healthier and we hope to have a
better year in 2017
clearly the state of the global economy
and particularly in the big four market
in which we sell is going to determine
how 2017 will go for us and I think
whilst we feel cautiously optimistic and
that's the phrase we use we expect the
u.s. to continue to grow but it remains
to be seen what the ink policy of the
incoming administration in the US might
mean for us what a stronger dollar might
mean for us the United States is by some
way our most important market it
represented just over forty five percent
of global diamonds sold last year
polished diamond state diamonds which is
a tremendous number China is the next
biggest market if you add Hong Kong and
Macau into China you're at about 16
percent and India is about 8 percent so
I think we're well positioned in it as
an industry for the future you know the
u.s. promises to continue to grow it
actually did very well in 2016 but the
opportunities for us to sell to an
expanding middle class in places like
China and India are enormous
it had a very powerful effect in a very
short term on India for us
India represents about 8% of the diamond
jewelry consumption around the world but
a very considerable proportion of the
rough diamonds produced around the world
are cut and polished in India even if
they weren't ultimately sold in India
and I think the lack of cash in the
system from mid-november caused the the
midstream to stop in India and so we
found that the factories the cutting and
polishing factories which are largely in
Surat in Gujarat province didn't reopen
after the Diwali holiday and I think
that did affect sales in the last two
sites of last year interesting that
we've seen some positive momentum in the
early part of the year a number of those
factories have now reopened not as many
as there are so they stole some
opportunity for some more website but
the demonetized a shock as I think
starting to work its way through the
system I think we need to remain
cautious for the rest of the year on
India but it's a huge market with
enormous potential for the years